ناجون يتفحصون الأنقاض بعد
سلسلة من الضربات الصاروخية المميتة التي
اندلعت هذا الأسبوع بين
إيران وباكستان مما أدى إلى إضافة الوقود إلى
منطقة مشتعلة بالفعل.
تشترك الجمهوريتان الإسلاميتان إيران وباكستان في
حدود طويلة يسهل اختراقها خلال فترة 48 ساعة
حملتها جيوشهما
قصف متبادل بطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ
على أراضي الطرف الآخر
وأزمة غير متوقعة لجارتين
بدا قبل أيام فقط أنهما يتفقان يوم
الثلاثاء، أجرى رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
محادثات مباشرة مع
كبير الدبلوماسيين الإيرانيين في دافوس الله، ولكن
بعد ساعات نفذت إيران ذلك  أطلقت ما
أسمته ضربات صاروخية وطائرات بدون طيار دقيقة
على من زعم ​​أنهم
إرهابيون إيرانيون في منطقة بلوشستان الباكستانية
وأدانت باكستان ما أسمته
انتهاكًا لسيادتها أدى إلى مقتل
طفلين على الأقل ويوم الخميس
رد الجيش الباكستاني أه
هذا الصباح قامت باكستان بهجوم  سلسلة
من الضربات العسكرية الدقيقة والمنسقة للغاية
ضد مخابئ الإرهابيين في
مقاطعة سانو بلوشستان
الإيرانية باستخدام طائرات بدون طيار قاتلة وصواريخ وذخائر
متسكعة
يقول الجيش الباكستاني إنه استهدف
مسلحين انفصاليين من المجموعة العرقية البلوشية
تقول السلطات الإيرانية إن 10
أشخاص على الأقل قتلوا مما دفع طهران إلى
في الواقع، نفذت إيران هذا الأسبوع
ضربات صاروخية ضد
شمال العراق
وسوريا، وهو استعراض مميت للقوة بعد أن
أعلن داعش مسؤوليته عن انفجارين مزدوجين
في مدينة كيرون الإيرانية يوم
3 يناير والذي أودى بحياة العشرات من المدنيين أه
كان هذا حقًا أه في المقام الأول
مظاهرة القوة في مكان
اعتقدت إيران أنه ستكون له
تداعيات محدودة أه من حيث أه أه
خطر التصعيد أه أعتقد أنهم
استهانوا كيف أه هذا سيضع أه
الحكومة الباكستانية في
موقف صعب للغاية أه من جانبها
يبدو أن الحكومة الباكستانية  أن تكون على استعداد
لتهدئة إيران فهي
دولة شقيقة وشعب باكستان يكن
احترامًا كبيرًا ومودة
لشعب
إيران. والسؤال الآن: هل يريد تيان
صراعًا مع جارته المسلحة نوويًا والأكثر سكانًا؟